And now it's the old scout master.
The other day I got into an elevator and there were a couple of guys in there already.
The door closed. we start our elevator ride and one guy turns to the other
And he says I heard this great scout master joke
And you know, immediately I stopped him.
I said: hey, just, you know, before you tell a joke like that,
you should know that I'm a scout master,
Oh, he said. he said: oh, oh, oh, oh yeah.
Well, I'll tell it real slowly so you can understand.
Hey, this is podcast number 68.
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green,
Heard from Jeff Swart on the blog this week
And Jeff wrote to say: hey, Clark, what a great show
Website service you offer to the scouting community-
The spirit of scouting indeed.
Well, thanks, Jeff.
Thanks for the Advancement Guide PDF.
For your information, I found a link to the 2009 edition of the Advancement Guide.
So here's what probably happened, Jeff:
You probably read an older post-
It might be months or years old- where I linked to an earlier edition of the Advancement Guide,
And in that case, you would want to definitely check and make sure that there is no addition that supersedes whatever I used to link to
And I'll take some time when I can to go back in and fix those kind of things.
But, Jeff, you guys are all my quality control people and I really appreciate it when you point something like that out.
So thanks for being in touch.
If you spend any time at the blog, which is at scoutmastercgcom, you'll see that there's a new contributor there on the blog-
Well, not absolutely new, because he's been commenting on blog posts and participating and he was even part of a podcast interview last year-
And that is Larry Geiger.
Now Larry is a very experienced scoutmaster down in Florida and he's got a very impressive scouting resume
And he's always made significant contributions in the way of comments and things on the blog
And we've had some email exchanges and things like that.
And I'm thinking: well, I wanted to move Larry's experience of viewpoint to a higher profile,
So I've gone ahead and made him a contributor-
How about that?
And he's going to produce some articles and thoughts that we'll share with you. on the blog,
You can see a profile of Larry and get an idea of who he is and what he does,
And the first post that we put up, the first article that we put up from Larry is about his camping boxes.
Yeah, not a whole lot of deep philosophy there,
But he has a couple of boxes that he takes camping, fills with cook gear, and he's got some very specific selections on it
And good reasoning for it.
And this is really great because it's like looking over the shoulder of somebody with a great deal of experience.
you know has been doing that monthly camp out for ages and ages.
Hey, what do you take with you?
Well, here it is,
And we've got pictures and explanations of all the stuff that Larry has,
And so I think this is going to be really cool.
What I want to do is kind of start a little show and tell thing.
So you have something that you take camping, you know, or maybe you have a camp box, like Larry, that you throw in the pickup truck or the van or the car when you go camping,
And it's just stuff that's proven to be useful over time and things
Let's share,
Let's, you know, take a couple of pictures, tell me what it's all about and send it on in
And we'll put it up on the blog
And I think it'll be great fun
And it doesn't have to be elaborate or anything.
You know a lot of times the simplest things are the most ingenious and important.
So if you have some hints or, like I say, a favorite piece of gear or something like that, send it in.
You can get in touch with me by email at scoutmastercg at Verizonnet.
Scoutmastercg at Verizonnet.
One more little bit of business here.
I'm a little late in announcing this, but our April giveaway winner is Mark Chesborough.
Mark is a committee chair with PAC 186 in Cookville, Tennessee,
And Mark says that he enjoys the newsletter and the website.
He says they're thought provoking for one who's recently rejoined the BSA and it's soon to move up to Boy Scouts with his son.
Thank you for your work.
Well, thanks for participating in the giveaway.
If you're not a subscriber to the Scoutmaster newsletter, go ahead and go to scoutmastercgcom,
Click the subscribe link and you'll receive a monthly newsletter
And each newsletter has giveaway from one of our affiliate sponsors. this past month, in April,
It was the folks at Little Bug Stove who donated your choice of a junior or senior. Little Bug wood burning stove-
Little lightweight thing that you can take camping.
There's a review of it at scoutmastercgcom if you're interested.
But Mark answered a trivia question and he was chosen randomly out of everyone who gave the correct answer to that question
And he won the giveaway.
So once again, thanks for being in touch, Mark, and congratulations on the giveaway.
The rest of this podcast is taken up with an interview I conducted last week with a fellow named Alex Koseff.
Alex is the author of the Appalachian Mountain Club Guide to Outdoor Leadership.
I know that some of you have already got this book and you've read it and you've benefited from it.
If you want a college level course on outdoor leadership, this is the book.
This is the one that you want to have.
It's very well written, It has a lot of good information in it,
And in the course of the interview, Alex shares a tip about working with teenagers that I have not heard before
And I think it's actually fairly revolutionary.
It's probably going to save me a lot of angst.
You know, listen to the interview and see if you can pick it up.
I'm going to stop talking about the interview so we can actually listen to it.
There will be some resources on the blog post that contains this podcast at scoutmastercgcom,
As you can get in touch with Alex and some training resources and things like that.
But hey, I've said enough, Let's get started.
Today I'm speaking with Alex Pasek, the founder and director of the Outdoor Safety Institute in Bozeman, Montana.
We're speaking to Alex from Bozeman
And he's also the author of the American Mountain Clubs Guide to Outdoor Leadership,
which, if you haven't seen it yet, folks, it's a great resource for anybody leading groups in the outdoors
And I think it's one of the things that any scout leader who's doing any kind of an ambitious outdoor trip should have in his library.
How are you doing, Alex?
I'm doing well. I'm pleased to be able to speak to you today, Clark.
So how did this whole outdoor thing begin for you?
I grew up actually on the East Coast in Rhode Island and I was always near the ocean
And the first kind of real outdoor exposure I had was just kind of exploring the coastline of Rhode Island and did a lot of fishing and snorkeling.
It also was, you know, my family did a lot of family camping and kind of doing getting outside
And that just sparked a love for it. that started like continued into high school when I started doing outdoor activities with friends
And then into college when I, you know, I really started backpacking and doing other activities more in a wilderness setting and then leading trips for my college outdoor club as a volunteer
And started working in the summers leading wilderness trips for teenagers.
So Rhode Island- you got into the Whites and the mountains of New Hampshire and Maine and things like that. or Massachusetts,
That was my kind of. my first love were the Whites.
In some places I spent a lot of time, including some of that time I was working for the Appalachian Mountain Club
But spent a lot of time there- the mountains in Maine to New Hampshire.
Where did you go to college? I had it on the resume here, but I
I actually went to college in Minnesota. I went to McAllister College, which is in St Paul,
And somehow landed in a spot that didn't have mountains, which,
But you went canoeing.
Yes, I did. I did get to do a lot of canoeing and actually I learned to rock climb in Minnesota.
There's actually some good small rock climbing areas there.
I mean I don't actually regret it at all. It's a really great college experience.
And now you're in like one of the big outdoor mechas of the US out there in Bozeman,
Yeah, I mean I can be skiing, fishing, rock climbing, hunting, backpacking- all within 15 to 20 minutes in my house,
An hour from Yellowstone. It's a pretty amazing place to be able to live.
That is amazing.
The guide when it first came out- I think the first edition was published around 2003..
And I got a copy of it then. It was really, really useful.
It was around the same time that we started doing some extended canoe trips with our scouts.
It taught me a great deal. The second edition was just released, September of last year.
What do you think the big differences are between the first and the second edition?
First off, the second edition just is a little bit more refined and readable.
There was a lot more effort put into the editing of this one,
So it's just that much more accessible.
Secondarily, there were some big new pieces added,
One of them on teaching and facilitation, a lot more on safety and risk management in the outdoors.
And then the biggest piece that was added and a big focus in this edition
is on needing youth in the outdoors,
And that's something that the Appalachian Mountain Club, who was the publisher,
as well as myself, are really interested in is kind of reversing the trend
of declining youth participation in outdoor activities
and making sure kids are exposed to the outdoors.
The real foundation of the book is in your definition of good outdoor leadership.
What can you tell me about that?
The way I define it is that outdoor leadership has three kind of foundational components.
In the book I kind of use the metaphor of a three-legged stool
and each leg is important for supporting your overall outdoor leadership ability.
But those legs or foundations are technical skills, interpersonal skills and judgment skills.
And technical skills are what you know, that's, your ability to know how to set up tents
and cook food and navigate and all those kind of things.
Interpersonal skills, you know, are the ability to work with other leaders
and with members of your group in a harmonious way.
And then judgment skills: the ability to see what's going on around you,
both in the environment and in your group and even with yourself,
and be able to assess what's going on and make good decisions.
And you know I certainly focus on safety in the book,
but it's also that judgment also relates to producing a good outcome,
a good educational experience or a good overall experience
for the participants in your group as well.
The judgment piece- you can learn some things about it through reading,
but it's mostly an experience-based skill, wouldn't you say?
Absolutely, You know, and that's what I say in the book-
is that this book is a framework, it's a starting point,
but the best leaders are the ones who are getting that hands-on experience
and developing those judgment skills based on experience.
That said, I do think there's room in there for developing those judgment skills
through really good training programs.
And some of the Wilderness First Aid type courses and leadership courses out there
that try and put you in simulations or scenarios
can really help develop some of those judgment skills.
But at the end of the day, nothing beats experience working with
and leading groups in the outdoors for building up those judgment skills.
In Scouting we have a pretty good training program
but it's mostly about scouting.
Some of it is about outdoor skills but it's a relatively small percentage of it.
You mentioned the Wilderness First Responder training
and in addition to that, what are the other opportunities out there
for people to get some really good scenario-based outdoor leadership training?
Unfortunately, Clark, there's sort of few and far between.
I mean, in different parts of the country there's opportunities.
The Appalachian Mountain Club in the Northeast
operates a program called Mountain Leadership School
which is a five-day program that's very scenario-based.
A well-known one is the National Outdoor Leadership School,
which offers some phenomenal courses, primarily in the western US,
and some international stuff.
Those tend to be longer courses, at least two weeks,
and often a month or longer.
There's also a lot of other smaller regional organizations
that do offer some good scenario-based training.
Let's talk about this Wilderness First Responder course.
I was able to take that and I thought it was great.
It was fairly easy.
I did it over a course of two Saturdays a year or so ago.
How would you encourage somebody to go and take that course?
I think that the two-day Wilderness First Aid course
is just absolutely critical for anyone who's venturing
outside of the reach of the quick response
from the 911 and EMS network.
I've dealt with quite a few backcountry emergencies,
some of them life-threatening.
It's so important to be able to fall back
to that basic framework about what to think about first.
what are your steps in your process
of dealing with that situation?
I encourage people to take that course whenever I can
You go on in the new edition of the book
and elaborate on some techniques
that can be used with teenagers?
Most of our scouts are going to be participating
in these kinds of activities,
or at least 13 and up to 17, 18 years old.
What's new out there?
Honestly, Clark, I don't know that any of it's totally new.
Some of this is good practices
that good people, good leaders in the scouts,
in mountain clubs in Outward Bound
and other organizations have been doing for decades,
But what I'm trying to do is put it together
in a coherent manner and make it a neat package
for people in some ways.
So the thing that is really important to me
is that the outdoor experience
be something that's different from teenagers' normal life.
If you go out there and you you know,
it's kind of a situation that they experience
much like they're at home, where teachers or parents
are always telling them what to do.
it's not going to be nearly as valuable
as if you give the teenagers some progressive responsibility
to take on ownership of the activity,
And I think that's something that's really missing
for a lot of youth today,
And so what I'm suggesting is that progressively
turn over responsibility for the trip
so that teens are really both responsible for things,
which they aren't always.
So they have to pack their own canoe, cook their own food,
and if they don't do a good job, there are consequences.
They take over more responsibility
And eventually, by the end of a- you know, a week-long trip,
they may be doing all the navigation and you as a leader
may be sort of watching from a distance
to make sure that nothing goes catastrophically wrong,
but giving them a little bit of a leeway
to make some mistakes that aren't going to be,
you know, have any real harm or safety repercussions,
And I think that that experience is something
that is really valuable in terms of building interest
in the outdoors but also building, you know,
overall life skills, decision-making skills
for the teenagers
And, ultimately, the activities we're doing in the outdoors.
you know there's some safety issues
There's, you know there's some skill involved,
but they aren't that complicated.
They're a fairly discreet set of skills
and you can train people in those pretty quickly,
especially if they're not, you know
we're not talking about, you know,
climbing glaciated mountains, but you know
the kind of basic activities we do in the outdoors.
The other thing I think is important is kind of finding
the right balance of challenge and reward.
And I've been with groups and I've seen other groups
out there on the trail where they just kind of
on these huge marches
And that can be rewarding if everyone's bought
into the idea of accomplishing a lot of miles
and getting something done.
But sometimes, you know, giving the group a chance
to climb a peak with an amazing view
and having a real feeling of success that way
may be more important than pushing them
really, really hard or having the opportunity
to have a campfire at night, you know,
after a solid day of paddling
is more important than getting in your 30 mile
paddle that day.
So there's this fine balance of figuring out
what's the appropriate amount of challenge for a group
and how can the activities that you're doing
be rewarding, either through a sense of accomplishment
or also some kind of other you know,
a view or a, you know, a fun night
on the campfire or something like that.
So it's not all about covering miles,
No, I mean, I think that some of the groups that
you know have gotten the most
that I've led, that have gotten the most out of it,
have had their challenging days
and they've had to push a bit, but they've also had
easier days where there were a lot of fun things:
swimming a lake- you know fun things
to do out there too- and a chance to bond
with teenagers in a way, other teens
in a way that they don't always get to do
at home.
There's a bit of advice that you give
that you may be unaware of that. it's pretty
unique, but I haven't seen it anywhere else
other than in your book, and that,
especially when working with teenagers,
is feeding them
and frequent snacks and things like that.
I mean that actually never really occurred to me
And what can you tell me about that?
I think it's brilliant.
Well, it's something that I mean.
I've heard this from other people,
but I've also had this experience:
The group morale and motivation
and energy just sort of
precipitously dropping and all of a sudden
kids who were really excited to be there
they're not anymore
And it took me a while to put it together.
but often some food will
really really help to solve that situation.
And the science behind that is
teenagers have really really high metabolism levels
and they need to eat a lot more frequently
than most adults do to keep up their blood sugar levels.
And when those blood sugar levels drop,
attitudes really go south
And it has a huge impact
on the ability of the group
to work together and get things done.
The key there is that if you're at all hungry,
your group is almost certainly-
almost certainly- hungrier than you are
And maybe not even be that tuned into that.
but making sure people have the opportunity to say,
hey, I need a snack,
And even encouraging that,
before people bring it up,
is a great way to keep the group moving.
Just feed and hydrate your group.
It's not just the food, the water helps a lot too.
It's one of the most basic but helpful tips
I've ever come across.
I got to tell you, I know this.
I think I knew this at some level,
but it was never like a part of the plan
And that is worth the price of admission
on the book alone.
Well, it's just hugely important
And you're right, all of us who've done any work
with scouts have encountered this
in one way or another.
All of a sudden, everybody just kind of hits the wall.
They start dropping like flies.
You're wondering what the heck is going on.
It's just a granola bar away, really,
Exactly.
Another piece of that, too,
is teenagers, especially males,
have incredibly high appetites.
They can really really eat a lot of food,
And most American boys
are used to getting all the food that they want.
And, of course, if you're backpacking,
you have to carry that food.
But my advice in general is,
especially when you're packing for teenage boys,
is: pack on the heavier side.
Carry a little bit more than to have
kids who are complaining about being hungry
or potentially really are hungry
and don't have the food to keep themselves well fueled,
And they don't normally associate hunger
with a drop in morale or a drop in behavior.
They just get cranky.
Exactly,
They're not even aware:
wow, I'm hungry.
That makes me cranky,
that's the fact of what I'm doing.
They just go there
And so being able to notice that
is pretty golden.
That's excellent.
One of the things that I really found useful
when I got the first copy of this book-
and it's in the second edition
and it's a little expanded-
is your discussion on expedition behavior.
Why is expedition behavior different
from evening meetings that we have
and things like that?
Because expedition behavior is that
you're really interdependent upon each other
and the group isn't going to function well
if people aren't working together
in somewhat of a harmonious way.
It really comes out of kind of expeditionary
climbing, like climbing big heat peaks
in the Himalayas or in Alaska.
but the concepts are very applicable
to any outdoor kind of experience,
especially multi-day ones.
but it sort of begins with
the idea of self-awareness,
so being aware of what your own needs are,
and then it flows into the idea
of taking responsibility
for taking care of your own needs.
A classic example is somebody
goes off to dinner
and leaves their sleeping bag out
and it starts to rain
and then their sleeping bag is wet
And that has an impact on the entire group
because they didn't take
on their own kind of self-leadership
and taking care of their own things.
And then it moves on from there
to the idea of being kind of supportive
of group goals,
so committed to group goals,
tolerant of each other.
I'm sure you've had this experience.
People come into these things
with different comfort levels
for being in the outdoors
and different physical ability levels
And it's often easy
for those who are more comfortable
or physically able to be,
let's see, like critical
or not supportive of those
who are less comfortable.
but if people are supportive
within the group and committed
to the group goals,
that support can really really help
those people who are struggling through,
can make them feel more
part of the group
and it can help them
to really overcome some of those challenges
and make the experience a success.
And another piece
of that whole expedition behavior
is good communication
and being able
to express yourself in a
supportive, non-critical way
with other members in the group.
So the expedition
behavior concept is something that
leaders really need to
have in themselves,
but it's something that the whole group
can really
commit to. and one of the things
that I like to do with groups
of teenagers particularly
is introduce this kind of concept
of expedition behavior- or you can
call it something else, if you want-
early on and have the group
help to define what the
expectations of each other are.
And you might have to prompt them a little.
Do you say, do you want people to be
supportive when you're having a hard time
or do you want them to be critical?
They're inevitably, especially
within the scouting community, they're going to understand
the value of being
supportive and
that early commitment from the group
to those concepts can be really
helpful later on, when all you have
to do is kind of say: hey, remember,
early in the
trip we talked about expedition
behavior and being supportive
of one another when we're having a hard time.
and for a lot of teens
that'll really click and they say: oh yeah,
you know, Joe's having a hard
time. now's not the time
to complain about
him slowing us down. now's the time
to maybe take a little weight from him
and joke with him a little and try
and share. You hit on something else
that I think in their limited
awareness, teenagers don't always
realize If they're
uncomfortable or if they're physically incapable
of doing something, they
get kind of afraid and they get very reluctant
and they get really recalcitrant-
I think that's the word I'm looking for-
about moving ahead
or trying to do anything. and I don't
think that they associate- just like they don't
associate being cranky
or difficult
with not having enough to eat
or drink- they don't associate
the fact that they're kind of afraid
or uncomfortable with
something, with the way that they
behave.
So, understanding
that and kind of
inculcating in the group
these expedition behaviors that you're talking
about,
you're going to avoid an awful lot of that
Absolutely. I mean that's
so critically important.
I really believe in outdoor experiences
and a kind of concept of
challenge by choice.
You shouldn't
be out there forcing people
to do something that they don't want to
do, Although there might be situations
where you have to get through
a bunch of miles because you have to finish the trip.
But for the most part,
if that group can be supportive
of one another, you
really avoid those situations
where you call that recalcitrant,
where teens get
really reluctant to do stuff,
and often- you're right, they cannot verbalize:
I'm scared,
I'm tired, I'm hungry.
but if the groups really supporting
each other and
the teens- the boys are having
easier time- are really
supportive and encouraging
and helpful to those who are having a harder time.
the
net accomplishments the group
can achieve are so,
so much higher than
if you let the
people having a hard time drag at the back
of the pack
and feel miserable for themselves.
It's really really crucial
to understand these dynamics
and then to put them to work.
So let's spend a little time just going over
some of the techniques
that you have in the book as far as leaders
and group development goes.
In encouraging group development,
it's helpful to understand that there's
kind of a natural group
development process that most
groups go through when they're on an
outdoor experience, and there's some variation,
but the
basic stages are forming, storming,
norming, performing,
and then there's kind of one called a journey.
So basically, what happens is
when people first come together
for an experience, they're kind of
excited to be there.
They're trying to get a sense of what it's all about,
who the other people are,
but then,
as challenges set in
and as they have to cook together
and sleep in tents together
and hike long miles together,
they get into a storming stage
where there's some conflict
amongst group members potentially.
and that's actually not bad.
It's okay to have some of that conflict
because it helps to establish
how the group's going to work together.
But if you can help facilitate that
by setting some of those
expedition behavior expectations,
really that's helpful.
Then you move into
kind of a norming phase
which is figuring out
how we work together
well,
Leaving the fighting, the storming,
the argument behind,
but working better together.
and then from that norming
you get into a performing stage
where the group can really really work well together.
and not every group gets there.
It depends on the leadership,
the activity you're doing, the length of the program,
the participants.
and then the adjourning phase is kind of
the hey, we're leaving
and people starting to realize
that this isn't going to go on forever
and that people are going to go
and sort of separate
at the end of the trip
At each stage of this.
there's no science
to this. it's really more of an art.
but it's being able to kind of
to step back as a leader
and not
impose your own
perspective, as much as trying
to look at the group
and how people are interacting
and even how they physically
look.
Are they kind of lazily
lily, dipping their paddle in the canoe,
or are they? did they have
their head down and they're looking miserable,
backpacking, or are they kind of
determined looking?
and those little observations
about individuals
and groups can really help
you understand who needs
support, how you might
be able to encourage certain
people who
and the groups doing really well
and you might be able to
task them with helping
other group members for struggling a little more.
So that
assessment thing- there's no
rule book for it
but it's being able to kind
of leave behind your own
perspective, your own
perhaps tired state,
struggling, hiking, or
your own viewpoint
and really look objectively at what's
going on in the group and try
to help the group
move through some of their challenges
and work together to achieve
a greater good.
Scouters will be pretty familiar-
well, at least ones who have been through some of the more advanced
training, like wood badge and things
would be, are going to be real familiar
with the storming, norming and forming
and the forming, norming, storming
or the inks and those dynamics.
but you know, just being cognizant
of these processes
is such an incredibly important
thing. When you're working in that
kind of group development
phase and you're getting
through that, you're also minimizing
a lot of
possible difficulties you're going to run into.
I want to spend
some time talking about a very important
part of the book, which is
risk management. Here's
what I think, Alex. I think a lot of us run
into it in our professional lives
and there's somebody
who is like the risk manager
and nobody really wants to see that guy come through
their office door. but I'm
a big advocate of understanding-
especially in
these kind of outdoor adventures, the
role of risk management, and I know
that you spend a lot of time assessing this
stuff. so give me a starter
course in a couple of minutes
here. What if I'm
headed off
to take a group canoeing for a week
or backpacking for a week? what
is it that I need to be thinking about
that? I might not know. Here's
summary there is that a lot of people
don't really want to deal with.
the risk manager is very
accurate, and this is
primarily what I do
for a living actually is
help. outdoor
programs deal with safety
and, to some degree, liability issues,
and one of the things
that's really important to me before delving
into the course
idea is that as a
culture, we're very
risk averse, we don't like
danger, and I think
it's really important and I think
that the scouts actually really help
to encourage this
in our society a little, to understand
that life
and also rewarding
growth experiences
have risks and we
can't eliminate all of those risks.
but at the other
side of it is my advocacy
for risk
doesn't mean that it's
an excuse for not
conducting the activities
and the outdoors that we do in a
responsible way. So there's
a lot we can do to make
the activities we're doing a little bit
safer. but at the end
of the day there is always going to be risk
and every trip that goes out
should have some level
of a risk management plan.
what are the likely
hazards that are going to be
encountered in? really three
areas. One, the particular
environment we're in.
is there going to be a big river crossing
we're going to have to do,
and potentially could the water be high
on that river crossing?
then the activity
we're doing is, if it's
backpacking,
is one of the hazards may be
lightning up on a peak
or a ridge, or is it swimming
in a remote, cold pond
lake? and then
hazards within the group- and that's
a really important one- is
looking at who's going
and thinking about the physical,
emotional,
health needs of the participants
in that group and are there
special steps you need to take
for those, Everything you
identify as a risk.
there's a little process
of kind of
figuring out: can we,
is there a way we can reduce
the risk? can we
eliminate it potentially
if it's not important to the activity,
or can we just say
that that's an inherent risk
that we need to accept as part of this?
so, looking at those things
and thinking about how can you modify them
without taking all the fun out of it,
there's the looking at things in advance
and how are you going to deal with them,
knowing how to respond
if something does go wrong.
this just isn't because
there is a fear
of being sued
or some liability
problem or something like that. this is for real
and this is how
you can kill people
if you don't do this,
and that's a tricky balancing act.
people often view this safety
stuff as being driven
by the liability thing,
but I work with some of the best
lawyers who specialize, actually
in defending organizations
from lawsuits
and they all,
front and center, tell you
that don't bother
with any of this stuff-
safety stuff in risk management-
if all you're concerned about is being sued.
you do it because you care
about the people you're taking into
the outdoors
and that you want to provide these experiences,
but you also want to do it
in a conscientious manner.
it takes a bit of an ego to be a scout leader
and
there's a lot of bravado involved
and things like that,
and I think it's particularly valuable having someone like yourself,
who has a little perspective on this
and who actually studies these things,
to back up the idea
that this is really important.
there are some hazards out there.
it's not disproportionate.
I mean, if you look at some statistical
information,
other activities
these teens could be doing
are much more hazardous,
including a lot of
common high school sports are much more hazardous
than the type of
outdoor activities we're talking about.
but at the end of the day,
what do you think the most dangerous part of
going on
a backpacking
or canoeing trip did?
I know the answer?
that's getting in the car and driving there.
absolutely
make sure people are doing basic stuff
like wearing seatbelts,
driving a speed limit,
not driving
when you're exhausted after
at the end of a long day,
perhaps hiking out to the trailhead.
so that's where you can really
have an impact too.
these are things that you have to keep
in the forefront of your mind
when you're leading this kind of thing.
it's just incredibly important
for Captain and Mr Buzzkill.
now we're just,
I know,
and it's really tempting.
I know how tempting it is to get out there
and you're having a good time
and you don't want to deal with this stuff.
but at the end of the day,
if it becomes kind of a systematic approach
and it's just how you as a leader
do things and it's how your scouts
in the group
are used to doing things,
it's less of a,
it's less of a buzzkill.
I think it's really actually
liberating because if you're
sure, or at least
reasonably sure, of your skills
and you're reasonably sure of
you've taken a time
and sat down and sketched out
a risk management plan
and you've done your best to
assess all of the different
things that you're going to do
and what considerations
you're going to need to have
and where you can bug out if you need to get out,
it's pretty liberating because you don't have to
make that up on the spot
now.
well, I really appreciate you having taken the time
to talk with us and
I've got to say
the book, which is
the American Mountain Club
Guide to Outdoor Leadership-
Appalachian Mountain Club-
okay and it's.
it's an excellent resource
to definitely give you
a big leg up in learning
how to be a really effective,
intelligent outdoor leader.
so, Alex,
thanks again for taking the time to talk to us
and,
you know,
try and keep warm out there in Bozeman
until what about July?
pretty ski season last until July.
so yeah,
but thanks, Clark, I really appreciate.
it's fun to talk to you
and people can also feel free to
contact me.
they can head over to our website
at OutdoorSafetyInstitutecom
and you can contact me
off of that website
or look at what we've got available on the website there.
well, thanks very much,
bye, bye.
well, thanks for listening
to this edition of the Scoutmaster
podcast. now here's
how to keep in touch.
you can read the Scoutmaster
blog at ScoutmasterCGcom
and, while you're there,
you can subscribe to the Scoutmaster
newsletter, which is a monthly digest
of the Scoutmaster blog and podcast
with some great scouting
resources around the world,
and you can find out more about
the Scoutmaster blog,
with some great scouting resources
around a monthly theme.
every newsletter includes a giveaway
from one of our affiliate sponsors.
you can subscribe to the Scoutmaster
podcast on iTunes and, when you do,
feel free to leave a comment or review
a rating, and you can also
call in and leave a voicemail
comment or question at
484-734-0002
and you could be on the Scoutmaster
podcast. how about that,
484-734-0002?
you can follow us at
Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
and ScoutmasterCG on Twitter,
and you can email me,
Clark Green, with your comments and questions
at ScoutmasterCG
at Verizonnet.
ScoutmasterCG
let me remind you that the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
no, hey, it's just me with a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and perhaps have a little bit of fun along
the way.
Now, before we leave you,
let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert
Bittenpal. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and
good camping.
I thank you, sir, Until next time
you.